guys we're huge fans of matthew morbius
matthew michael
morbius it's gonna be good now we got
coy with john united day because coy
he knows a lot about sir michael morbius
quite a bit make sure to follow him on
his youtube channel he's been posting
quite a lot lately let's get him to 10
000 followers before the end of the year
he's so close to 10k i have a pretty big
open mind about this morbius movie every
time i see new images i'm i'm like yeah
this looks pretty cool i think it's the
right tone to take to differentiate
itself and i think the universal monster
tone of a separate universe is the way
to land like an entire like new world
from the comic books because they're so
much harder in comics this is a great
way to build out from it
yeah john i'm very excited for more
strange schlocky sony movies
that's the honest opinion i was waiting
for
[Music]
skull island
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
if you're gonna rock an old palm cut
okay
all right guys here we go michael movies
you've been missing for two months
tyrese oh yeah tyrese is in this man
on the container ship get washed up off
the long island
right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that was from the comics
[Music]
fat radar sonar
[Music]
it's not oscar building
horizon and ice corp so far
i think he looks cool man i'm a fan of
the visuals look solid for him
cast a solid
there's something there
[Music]
that looks sick
[Music]
fascinating
yo
there's some really great visuals in
here
[Music]
in the universe venom joke is going to
work for me
i'm into that all right okay so we got
the venom reference there's a daily
bugle reference horizon labs dude that's
huge building in there let's go back to
that daily bugle magazine there's always
juicy details in there
hold on everyone daily bugle michael
morbius apprehended for vampire murder
rhino on the loose
zoo hoax fools us all but more
importantly perhaps black cat friend or
foe because we had the silver and black
script that was deeply in development i
think it's in like pre-production now we
have like that whole shared universe
starting with black cat i mean i don't
know if they're going to do the stuff
with felicity from amazing starfield was
yeah was in the amazing spider-man 2
yeah yeah because she was the assistant
roman osborne like very strongly setting
up a black cat universe but she was
supposed to debut with silver sable and
they were going to do like this assassin
movie between the morality of a thief
and the morality of an assassin and
sharing out like the crime world i'm
sure this is just an easter egg
very excited about it it was a separate
movie's gonna be about that one that
little top corner of a daily view but
the the universe in which this is
embodying is kind of confusing me now
because this would imply that this is
amazing spider-man world right like a
little bit future but then you have the
reference to venom did not show up an
amazing spider-man say raymond
spider-man on the wall and then you got
sam raimi spider-man on the wall and
then you got vulture from the mcu you
got the oscar building which is not the
one from amazing spider-man so we got
the daily bugle from the raimi movie it
seems like morbius is the real linchpin
to colliding with multi-version
this seems like some sort of multiverse
of madness yeah it could be maybe
they're all collided right here around
michael morgan this comes out before
doctor strange but after no way home so
whatever you was like let's let it all
happen
sure tomorrow morbid is essential
viewing laced exactly the right lineage
for everyone to understand but beyond
all the spider-man stuff and the
multiverse is it delivering the goods
that you were hoping i mean yeah it
looks like a crazy horror-centric
superhero movie of sorts i mean there
are certain parts that gave me the kind
of cheese that maybe i don't absolutely
want but can't help but enjoy from these
movies jared leto has that quality where
i'm like i know you can turn in a
quality performance also you as the lead
in a superhero movie i feel like could
be kind of a meme but in a good way so
i'm looking forward to this looks like
fun this does look like fun i feel like
this could be a better film than the
venom movies honestly i hear sass greg
as a devout venom devotee i hear you i
like where the trailer is leading here
with the do you remember that feeling
that we came with the first venom movie
when they're like he's supposed to be a
villain at first uh why are they making
him a hero right away this trailer seems
to be really honing in on his inner
complex that economy because he sets out
here to be a hero because of what
happens with the vampirism that is
occurring within his body he's now doing
some villainous deeds as we see on like
the ship sequence which is pulled
straight from the comics
i think they are setting up an actual
honed in anti-hero which is something
that we did not really get from when we
were watching the first venom movie that
was kind of upsetting some fans and here
i'm like at least they're dealing with
the complexity sure is he introduced as
a villain in the comics in the
spider-man world yeah and then does he
become an anti-hero yes but at least
they're dealing with the hero villain
complexity here it looks entertaining
and the effects are better than i
actually thought they would be now koi
silence us i think what's gonna be
interesting is to me like i said at the
top this is like a shared universal
monster movie universe where you've got
this insane tone you've got this fun you
know b-movie tone that i think really
works in a villain turned hero world and
i think it's a lot braver and bolder
than we're giving sony credit for this
is a unique take and all of it feels
weird enough that we just dove into
black cat silver sable theories just
from a corner of the screen because this
can expand out to a truly insane place i
do think it's interesting we're dealing
with three different potential
spider-man universes and what that means
especially with this happening in no way
home what if there is some sort of crazy
cataclysmic collision of universes and
we do have something where we have to
figure that out throughout these films
we don't know what happens in our way
home we don't have confirmation on
andrew and toby we don't actually know
how that universe shakes out so it would
be interesting with the character so
tied to spider-man so in the comic books
morbius is a living vampire who has a
blood disease as you see in this trailer
that cures himself but then you find out
his blood actually helps cure others so
he actually gets spider-man who at this
point has six arms back to two-armed
spider-man's the whole thing comic books
are crazy do it people think this is too
schlocky they should read six armed
spider-man comics this is actually very
totally appropriate me and then spider
bring the man spider sick
but also in the in the show which he was
very popular in the animated series he's
got like literal like palm suckers so
we've had a lot of morbius in pop
culture before but this is the way to
bring him into the mainstream this is
the way to bring him into the broader
universe and expand your universe out
without stepping on toes what this does
is allows us to have a different
tonality without it hindering their
spider-man directly without it hindering
anything else they might want to do
because this does feel like he would
know venom this does feel like it could
expand out one direction but then they
could still do other stuff with you know
your spider woman your spider gwen your
spider blank and i think it's really
smart to handle it this way because we
almost had morbius in the first blade
movie right right the end of 1998's
blade had morbius standing on top of a
tower right next to wesley snipes blade
and it'd be really ironic if 24 years
later we get blade and morbius well it
is interesting after let there be
carnage coming out too because the
carnage run um morbius helps fight
against carnage too so i thought that
that would be tying in but as you know
seeing the events let there be carnage
obviously that's not what we're gonna be
getting spoilers and then while i have
like the love relationship here with uh
you know i wanna be with my woman but i
can't this disease is tearing us apart i
think a big part of the heart of this
film might have to actually do with the
relationship that he forms with the
person who's actually hunting him down
tyrus gibson's character who was quite
like the comics
so he's gonna be the stephen graham of
this movie i hope so awesome i hope so
excited for tyrese i'm also excited to
see jared harris in anything he's
supposed to be his mentor right
absolutely supposed to be morbius his
mentor perfect i'm just personally
excited for matt smith i love watching
him in anything and in that michael
keaton part he says like uh michael we
should stay in touch but in that moment
i can't tell if it's trailer splicing
but it looks like vultures being
apprehended again while they're letting
morbius get away yeah that's what it
looked like to me too which intrigues me
because i i had always theorized that he
was gathering the sinister six himself
but we don't know obviously until the
movie comes out if i was right you're
way wrong you know i usually am
not anything i don't know anything about
i like the tinfoil hat theories more
than the logical ones that's who i am
i'm curious with the first the amazing
spider-man universe the andrew garfield
universe they made tech so predominant
everything was oscorp everything was
tech and then in the mcu they've made
spider-man very science-based which i
love they've made him this actual
committed to science character as much
as they've let him get the screen time
to do so i'm curious with this
science-based villain how much we get to
dabble in that world i really like the
idea of us making
that a bigger part of the character
because that's so important in the
comics to me oh yeah absolutely
especially in the spider-man world yeah
half his villains right there exactly
yeah
well there's so much like lizard stuff
with more views like you first meet the
lizard with morbius and they actually
solve lizard's problem with his blood so
i really hope they do some stuff like
that confirmed morbius is the sixth
member there it morbius is the sinister
six lizard mirrors the rest of the six
and then he's the only member left all
right guys well what did you think about
this morbius trailer leave your thoughts
down below do you think it leans too
much into spider-man references do you
think it doesn't lean enough in a
spider-man are you only watching this
because you like spider-man and you want
to see how this turns out does it look
like a genuine you know the questions
hey subscribe to koi's channel maybe
subscribe to us check out john on his
personal channel where him and his
family travel the world exploring exotic
locations filled with tribal children
we'll catch you guys soon that's true